take a look at this first one right here
so the absolute value of 2x minus 3 is
greater than or equal to negative 8
whatever is inside of this these two
absolute value bars it will always make
it positive so if you're taking the
absolute value of a negative quantity
it'll be positive if you take the
absolute value of a positive quantity
it'll be positive the smallest this
whole quantity can be after you take the
absolute value is going to be 0 that's
the smallest that it can be right so
whatever happens here once you take the
absolute value it's going to be 0 or
greater which means it'll automatically
be greater than or equal to any negative
number so the answer to this problem
without having to do any calculations is
that it's going to be all real numbers
or if you want to use the interval
notation negative infinity to positive
infinity
okay whereas this one here see the
absolute value of 5x plus 7 is less than
or equal to negative 2 once we take the
absolute value of whatever's in here
it's always going to be zero or positive
so that means it's off it's never going
to be less than or equal to negative 2
it's always going to be greater than
that so this one actually there's no
solution you could say empty set or if
you want to use the set brackets so
nothing inside here empty set or however
you want to write it no solution right
no solution so before you dive into
these if you see a negative number on
the right side of the inequality take a
look and analyze it to see if it's no
solution or if it's all real numbers now
the third case here that sometimes comes
up is at first you look at this and you
say hmm this isn't negative you know and
my teacher and tutor told me to watch
out for those negative ones right but
what you want to do before you get into
solving these absolute value problems is
you want to get the absolute value by
itself so if you divide both sides by
negative 3 right this is going to give
you negative 2 and when you multiply or
divide both sides by a negative number
what happens to that inequality sign it
changes direction right so now we're
left with 15 X minus 2 the absolute
value is less than or equal to negative
2 and now we're back to what we were
dealing with in this case here whatever
is here is going to be 0 or greater it
can never be less than or equal to
negative 2 so there's actually no
solution to this